on va se battre pied à pied c'est pas
une obstruction si on joue un rôle
parlementaire on n'est pas d'accord donc
on va se battre pied à pied comme on le
fait traditionnellement sur des
arguments
vous verrez à partir de lundi on a vécu
un moment n'est pas que le président de
l'assemblée 20 g 6 sur l'anguille oui
surtout qu'il a un côté politique aux
rigides être admise à manger écoutez moi
je les ai vus hier pour un vote je pas
si vous avez vu mais il a il a ouvert un
vote est il dans la seconde même il l'a
fermé ce qui fait que il ya plein de
gens y compris contre que comme nous
étions qui n'ont pas pu venir les de la
dir gens soient là c'est la méthode de
françois dumas pour l'instant je le
trouve voilà il faut peut-être qu'ils
mettent un peu de souplesse quoi il ya
peu d'adaptations world jours je sais
bien que c'est les règles de l'assemblée
moi j'ai posé une question il m'a coupé
le sifflet à 0 bon je sais que je sais
que monsieur bartolone et ses quelques
secondes pour essayer de finir de
tolérance voilà je pense que j'en
appelle à il va peut être évoluer il
apprend aussi